PABLO SUAREZ: At the Red
Cross/Red Crescent Climate
Center, our job is to help
others understand and address
what's going on
with climate change
and with extreme events--
hurricanes, typhoons, too
much rainfall,
peak temperatures.
And these things
are complicated.
This science is complex.
And how to turn
science into action
is not easy if you're
too busy to learn.
Most of our colleagues in
the humanitarian sector
are insanely busy.
When science is communicated,
it is very often
either incomprehensible
or difficult
to link to ongoing
humanitarian processes.
So about six,
seven years ago, we
started with creating
playful activities
where participants in a
workshop have to make decisions
that have consequences.
And that's at the core of games.
Games are systems where
you have to make a decision
with limited information.
You're trying to
accomplish something,
and you don't really know what
may happen because there's
something in the system
that you don't control--
which can be the weather.
It can be what other people do.
It can be just you're not
fully understanding the system.
In our experience as
humanitarian workers,
trying to infuse awareness
of complexity into our work,
games are the most wonderful
tool to wet the appetite,
to make people want to learn
more and want to do better.
It has been beautiful to
work with the MIT Game Lab.
We have, as Red
Cross family, access
to a lot of talent, a lot
of enthusiastic brain power
that combines
analytical competence
with creative juices.
That is prevalent in
the field of game design
and among students of games.
What we find at MIT is
that it's much easier
to link to other departments
that are directly
connected to what we do.
It can be about
environmental engineering.
It can be about climate science.
It can be about
technology development.
So this partnership is
the beginning of something
that is inevitably going
to grow, to grow beautiful,
to grow big.
It was also really nice
to see how the MIT Game
Lab is well-connected
to other partners
that we have in the game design
sector, such as the Engagement
Lab at Emerson or the
PETLab team at Parsons,
and the awareness of reach in
the world of serious games.
Games that are not just
as a playful activity,
but with the intention to
improve the world somehow.
We could always do better as
partners of the academic team
if we could allocate more time.
Unfortunately, it is in the very
nature of our Red Cross work
that we have to travel insanely.
I was out of the country for
at least half of the time
when the course happened.
So we did bring in partners
and friends who gave a hand.
But I think one of
the key challenges
for this kind of partnership
between game related academia
and humanitarian
teams is to find
ways to interact more
frequently, more deeply,
to learn about each other.
We just don't know
how we can do more
with the limited time we have.
When students engage
with partners, clients
from the real world,
it is not easy
for them to get into the
shoes of the institution
of the organization that has
to try to accomplish things.
So one of the most
important things
that we can offer as
partners in this course
was to give a flavor of the
context in which the game would
be played.
So we have the team working
on cholera prevention
in West Africa.
And they developed
a video game that
had the flavor of
modern wealthy homes.
And in West Africa, most of
our target audience-- if you're
trying to prevent cholera--
chances are they are poor,
and the aesthetics
need to resonate.
It can be about a
super stellar context,
or it can be about
a thatched roof,
but it should be something
that can evoke engagement
on the part of the player.
And that's not easy for
students to find out.
They actually have
to do research
on what does a home in
West Africa look like?
The other thing we can
do is to help narrow down
and focus on what matters to us
in terms of the gain in forming
better decisions, and to
weed away and filter out
all the things
that students want
to include because they can.
But that's not a
good enough reason.
Just the fact that it's
technically feasible
or that you like it, doesn't
mean that it should make it
into the final prototype.
There were many
other things that
were a lot of fun in
terms of engagement
with students that I
think were useful to them.
In particular, to
see how they could
get inspired by being aware of
how their technical competence
can be useful for development
work, for humanitarian work,
for actually physically
saving lives in the long term,
or to help people engage with
each other in other continents,
in other contexts, in fields
that they don't even know,
but they can help.
When an academic team is
offering student brain power
and air time during a
course for an organization--
specifically in games
but also more broadly--
it is our experience
that it takes more time
than we think to
develop the relationship
and to understand how we can
really get juice out of it.
And it is always worth starting.
If the client organization, if
the partner-- like in our case,
the Red Cross family--
can find someone
who spends a little bit of time
at the beginning, a little bit
of time reviewing
prototypes, and some feedback
along the way, it's
definitely worth it.
But don't expect
magic solutions.
Don't expect people to be
able to read your mind.
We come from
different universes.
And we have an opportunity
to bring the real world
to academia.
By just showing up
and spending time,
but also to bring academic
brainpower, talent,
and creativity into our work.
One of the things that I have
to say with enormous pride
is that one of the
prototypes that
emerged from one of the
groups in this course
was actually used in
three global events
and helped hundreds
of people in real time
learn what was
being thought about.
People entered three
words as individuals.
There were 100 or more
people in the room,
and everyone saw a word cloud
that emerged through very fun
game play.
And this can really
help, but we need
to be aware of the time
it takes to mature.
We have been working
with game designers
for at least six years.
And that really helped
us channel our energy
in a more narrowly defined way.
Otherwise, it's very easy to go
broad and to be disappointed.
Be prepared to acknowledge
your own limitations,
but be prepared to explore
the space of possibility.
So the game Snap is
already ready to deploy--
has been deployed.
I hope we can refine the user
interface to give more choices
to the facilitator and so on.
But that is one
game that I predict
will be able to change the
way real-world events happen.
I have that admission.
I think we can do
something with it.
Of the many other
games that were good
because they were more
about a subject matter that
is outside of Cambridge,
Massachusetts,
they will take more
time to refine.
I'm very excited about the
Cholera game, which we now
have a partnership with UNICEF.
And we anticipate the
demand from UNICEF Guinea,
in particular, to try
to add digital flavors
to their relationship to
schoolchildren in prevention
of anything-- in
promotion of the things
that help-- like hand
washing with soap,
which we take for granted here.
But in other parts of
the world, they just
have to choose
between soap and food.
It's hard to make that case.
And some of the other game
prototypes have very insightful
game mechanics-- how to display
territory in a small screen.
How to display quantities
for decisions in terms
of disaster preparedness.
The representation on a game
on heat wave of how people
can just collapse
if they think they
can just go out and walk on
an excessively sunny, hot day.
These are things that
are there, are latent,
and we have opportunities
to work deeper
either with these students or
with future students of MIT
and beyond.
They will need more
time to refine.
And we have, as Red
Cross, more work
to do in terms of identifying
the potential player
and identifying what are the
decisions that can be improved,
or what are the discussions
that can be enriched by engaging
in this game experience.
From the Red Cross/Red
Crescent Climate Center
and from the
humanitarian family,
I hereby thank profusely
the MIT Game Lab,
and by extension,
game designers that
have helped us become
partners with you
now, for setting up a space
where we can learn how
magically powerful but
analytically clear game play
can be to help accomplish
humanitarian goals.
Thank you so much.